and we are live welcome to another
YouTube hangout I'm really excited to be
on with you guys again with me is John
summers some tubs and they are doing an
article about advice for franchisees
tips that I might have and I said hey
why don't we turn this into our YouTube
hangout
so you guys can benefit from the
knowledge as well and also maybe learn a
little bit more about tubs so John maybe
if you wanna just give a quick intro on
some background and then far away with
your questions yeah sure thanks Evan I'm
working at tubs vending franchise we're
just the kind of small franchise based
in UK although expanding a little bit so
it can't do in America which is quite
nice at the moment and you know
basically we are low you know low cost
franchisee easy way to get into kind of
entrepreneurship which is series and
while we're talking stay and you know it
does exactly what it says it's in it's a
vending franchise you know you buy it
and you get some vending machines in
malls and shopping centers that kind of
stuff you know and it seems to go quite
well quite easy to manage so so it's a
nice easy way in franchises cool so
let's get into cool well what questions
you have how can I help with your
article yeah sure I guess what we do at
the moment is putting together kind of
expert tips obviously it's a big reason
why we're in touch for you to kind of
find out what you think the experts
think about franchises I guess compared
to kind of you know traditional way of
getting its businesses so I've got a few
kind of quickfire questions and then
some kind of franchise based questions
entrepreneurship Evan what's you know
how did you kind of gain to that what we
have what's your background with him why
do you love it so much
sure I started yeah I think I've always
been an entrepreneur I remember when I
was five I you know made pictures
drawings with my three or little sister
and we sold them door-to-door but I
didn't have any entrepreneur influences
in my family so even though I was doing
you know baseball cars and garage
sales and having up my own little
adventures when I went to you to high
school I thought hey I'm gonna you know
my high school yearbooks that I'm gonna
be a banker where are you gonna be in
ten years I'm gonna be a VP and a bank
that's where I was gonna be mostly
because I didn't have any you know I
didn't have anybody in my family who's
an entrepreneur my parents supported me
in anything I did but they all had you
know corporate safe jobs and then when I
was in university I connected with two
people who had a company and needed help
software company and I joined as an as a
test as a something fun and different to
do and I kind of fell in love with it
and and haven't looked back since so I
stumbled into it by accident I guess
from people who were in the business I
needed some help and I'm really grateful
for it because obviously I love it and
if I hadn't found that I call I would be
at a bank or some safe corporate eating
it don't you finish it you know there's
a lot of self-help books and you know
websites like your own which kind of
give a lot of information but you know
it's it's hard to get people motivating
know people often find it hard to get
into it do you think it's just
accidental kind of like the story folks
out there you know I think environment
matters I think your environment matters
and and because I didn't have that in my
environment it wasn't on my radar and I
think now is easier than ever to get it
on your radar right you couldn't you
know I have people who watch these
videos who are 13 years old who asked me
questions like I wish at my 13 year old
state I could ask somebody who's done
more than me about something that's
interesting right and so I think it's I
think it's making a conscious decision
to create an environment that supports
you and that that supports your
ambitions and your dreams and desires
and to allow you to explore your
curiosity
so I'm massively grateful for the
internet and all the people you know out
there now and I can now design an
environment that is better suited to me
but yeah we're you know
I've heard the expression your result of
your five friends you know it's it's
true you're gonna take the beliefs of
your parents the good ones and the
limiting ones and so the more you can
surround yourself with information and
content that supports you to think
different think outside your usual
comfort zone
it'll help ya I guess do you think you
just touched on technology there in the
inset do you think that's kind of a you
know a big helping hand especially
considering kind of twenty years ago but
you know before most was that kind of
dial-up connections you think the in
sense kind of helped more entrepreneurs
get out there now oh sure I mean it's
never been easier to start a business
whether a franchise business or your own
you know business from scratch has never
been easier and it's never we have more
role models now right like you can look
up to a Zuckerberg and and the young
entrepreneurs who are killing it
where before they weren't necessarily
around as much so I think it's way
easier to be motivated and and the
start-up costs have come down so much
that it's way easier to get started and
I mean I'm I'm 35 so I remember being on
a dial-up modem and getting started some
of the people watching now probably
aren't you know they what are you
talking about you know one computer per
house you know those are the days but
yeah a technology's definitely made it
so much easier to be an entrepreneur
yeah yeah about same have memory sort of
dial-up internet back in the day okay I
guess what would you say are the kind of
vital elements or the vital traits of
being an entrepreneur is it kind of
nature nurture you know do you think
that most people have a call set skills
to be an entrepreneur can we learn yeah
I think there are so it's interesting
because I've studied a lot of different
entrepreneurs and my website really is
the biggest collection of entrepreneur
stories the things that they have in
common are one that they have an idea
and that's not so uncommon and a lot of
people have ideas almost everybody has
idea for what they want to do - they did
something about it and that's a big gap
right they started somehow a lot of
people they don't they never start they
just sit back on their idea and then
they see somebody make you know millions
of dollars off of it - god I had that
idea and they become really I'm really
jaded and 3 they kept going they
persevered right because it's way harder
than you think it's gonna be and all the
things that people usually think about
like you have to be a type-a personality
you have to have a lot of money you have
to have the right education like none of
those things matter because you can you
know maybe yes the Donald Trump's of the
world and Richard Branson's and you know
that the the guys who have the bravado
they stand out more because they have
the bravado well there's tons of people
if you look at that you know the fortune
or the Forbes list of the you know
richest people in the world there's a
ton of people in there that you've never
heard of for all entrepreneurs and
they've got there by doing it their way
you can't be quiet and introverted and
still have massive success and so I
think the key is to to not try to change
yourself they're not trying to be like
Branson or Trump and be someone you're
not
but to go in on on what you're really
good at go all-in on your strengths and
as long as you you know take action on
your idea and you follow through on it
those are the critical factors to being
successful cool thank you
so I have a few coming franchise beta
specials now if that's okay as well yeah
so I guess obviously there's loads of
franchise out there now you've got loads
of articles about franchising on your
website which have kind of been free to
majority Elizabeth too much to go
through in title but why would you think
someone would choose a franchise over
going down the route of kind of starting
a business from scratch won't be the
pros and cons I guess
yeah the benefits of a franchise are
that it's a system like you don't go to
school to be an entrepreneur
there aren't many classes I mean I went
in University of Toronto probably the
most well respected University in Canada
I took a took a fourth year level course
in entrepreneurship and it was really a
joke like I was already running my
business and learning way more than I
learned in that class so you don't
really go to school to learn this stuff
and so a lot of people when they go in
this
a business they don't know what they're
doing like they don't have any of the
basic things that they need to get going
a lot of the infrastructure a lot of the
ideas what works on marketing what works
in operations what works in hiring they
don't know and they're trying to figure
it out as I go and a lot of people will
fail because of it where with a
franchise especially if you pick one
that you've done your homework and
research and they've had a track record
of success and they have a good training
program they give you yes you pay for
that a massive reduced cost compared to
what it would cost you to go and try to
figure all that on your own they give
you a system and if you follow the
system you'll be successful and so
there's a lot of people who who want to
do their own thing who want to be their
own boss but maybe they don't have the
vision or maybe they don't have
confidence in the you know they want the
training they don't have confidence in
their skills or abilities and the
franchise just makes a lot more sense
for them yeah cool and I guess the
golden question is what makes a good
franchise you know what would you look
out for if he were to take out a
franchise of some kind so in terms of
picking a good franchise that that's the
path you want to go one I would make
sure that I know and use the product
right if you are trying to sell pizza
and you hate pizza you know it's like
pick a different business right pick
something where you can talk
passionately about the products that
you're selling that you use them on a
regular basis in your daily life that
you would recommend to your mother that
she goes and and buys from you know this
product this company because if you
wouldn't then if you only look at it in
like dollars and cents you're not going
to be successful has to be something
that drives you because of what the
company is all about next I would love
to make sure that the company how they
operate is in line with what I believe
in and I'm good at right so do I have to
be in all-star salesman as an example
for this franchise to take off right
am i a mall star salesman
if I'm not then I don't want to pick
that franchise right so every franchisee
how its set up is built to support
certain kinds of people and hopefully
they do a good job too in kind of
weeding that out and explaining what
they're good at not but I want to
basically see if it's a match right
through my skills and interests and
abilities match up with what a
successful franchisee would be in this
company obviously I would look for some
kind of integrity from the company right
how do they treat their franchisees with
the with the internet you can look up
any franchise and quickly see is this
company reputable or not you know our
franchisees you know really upset at the
service that they're getting
I'd be looking at the training that I'm
getting from up above right is it I just
go to their does it look here's a manual
on that say is it I go to their
corporate headquarters once and that's
it I'm done do I have somebody you know
upstream that I can connect with on a
regular basis and are they doing spot
checks am i doing calls with them is
their training is their regular seminars
that I can join online or events you
know the more you're essentially buying
the system you're buying the training so
the more that there is that training
available to you the more that it's
going to make sense for you and so yeah
those would be kind of the main points
that I would look at it also in the
franchise cool yeah it's really good
I guess the main obstacle that we kind
of skim at the moment is if I can try
and call you do some of your gym or top
it be I mean there's lots of thing to
look out for is it the passion thing you
mentioned they're kind of choosing it a
franchise around the passion that you do
you view your kind of in to be the main
thing yeah for me it all comes down
still to the passion because you could
have a great company you know great
system great training yo you match up
well with the skill set but if you don't
have a passion for what you're selling
it's never gonna work where you could
overcome a lot of those other obstacles
if you really believed in what you were
selling so that's
that's the core for me the side of
everything you believe let's say you
said this is a good be good lead
actually so the believe campaign the
hashtag and everything you have say Stan
core obviously we know the word means
but ya know the idea behind it has to
come up with it why there
I came up because I wanted something I
wanted something more emotional to
relate to my brand I was having trouble
with the tagline and how to describe
myself and I used I took the McDonald's
approach for a while and said you know
over 20 million entrepreneurs helped and
Counting kind of thing but but I felt
like I want something a little more the
touch people in our heart I'm a passion
guy so I wanted something I would hit
people in the heart a little bit sooner
for me believe means one believe in what
you're selling so just like the answer
to your last question you have to
believe in the product to believe in
yourself so how the self confidence and
that's the usual definition I guess
people consider believe like self
confidence and three then just believe
that it's gonna work out that this is
really you know important for
entrepreneurs that you're you're you
know busting your butt you're working
really hard every day and you may not
see any light at the end of the tunnel
you're just in the cloud of darkness and
you got to believe that it's gonna work
out and so that's why I kind of branded
myself around it and ever since then
that's like I've seen a massive growth
in in my traction in my company my
audience because they also get something
that other people can talk about pretty
easily and so that's yeah yeah yeah you
know it sounds like we might have to get
you into a bit of consultation about
yeah there's a few questions but but we
can get yours too
I've got I've got one more week today
you know we can go to questions if you
that's fine yeah okay so it's really
about your site obviously is really
popular you've got loads of kind of
great articles on
you you no-good lazy followers etc
people asking questions now but when do
you see that like going you know what
we'll see the end goal with the site you
can be around for a long time now
the end goal is to help a billion
entrepreneurs I want to empower
entrepreneurs around the world and I
just don't care about the website I mean
what I care about is attention attention
is the currency so wherever the
attention is that's where I'm going to
be because I want to help entrepreneurs
and so what I'm trying to do is things
at scale so even like this interview as
an example like hey let's turn this into
a YouTube hangout so that other people
can benefit from it as well people watch
and they're gonna learn something from
it I mean it gives exposure for you guys
which is great too but it's trying to
help entrepreneurs and so the web is
obviously very important so I have the
website YouTube is where I'm spending
the ton of my time because that's where
a lot of attention is I'm on Twitter I
did a blab earlier today get involved in
periscope you know wherever the
attention is that's where I want to be
because that's my path to be able to
reach my goal of influencing and helping
a billion entrepreneurs and so what's
the future for the website I don't know
you know like if YouTube takes over the
world then I'll stop my website and go
all-in on YouTube or whatever a new
thing comes out that then dominates not
being attached I guess that I mean the
message is not being attached to a
specific platform but being attached to
the goal like what is your main goal
what do you want to accomplish and how
do we reach that cool so I'm you know
Facebook I'm not as in on from a content
marketing point of view this is a paid
platform for the most part like as a
brand is a paid platform the great thing
about Facebook is the ability to target
the target on Facebook is insane
converting the platform right if I
wanted to target you know stay-at-home
moms who like hard rock music and live
in Devonshire I could do it like there's
no way to do it except on Facebook right
and that be through dark posts
I can find those people right there
Facebook as a general platform I'm not
as bullish on unless you have budget big
budget to spend buying views but I think
you can get that impact elsewhere at the
moment so I'd rather be on YouTube video
than Facebook at the moment that may
change but that's my thoughts for now
cool so we have some people watching
Salvador's ready name I have a clothing
brand it's going to be a year it's a
good idea to get is it a good idea to
get investors at this early stage I have
two stores and I'm online
he's breaking even you want to take a
run at that I know it's not really nice
so like it terms of expanding investors
franchising might be a model to be able
to explain if you have one successful
location yes you know I guess we
franchises as well perhaps well and yeah
just lead on some of your answers there
we and kind of pride ourselves on very
low levels game very scalable in terms
of okay you know now I'm making back a
bit of return you know what what's the
next step I know let's take that model
let's take that system which you called
it and scale up to the next location so
I guess that's kind of you know the
model or the system that we have in
place op see every franchise is slightly
different but you know I guess that's
the descending point well particular
front choices of reeseville I'm not sure
to actually answers a question directly
does it Evan yeah so you've got two
locations he's breaking even in one year
should he get investors you know the bad
best the easiest networks
right that's why you buy into a
franchise because it's proven that it
works right if it hasn't proved that it
works why are you gonna drop money to
buy a franchise right and so it all
depends on how quickly you want to grow
because you can grow at your pace and
then own everything and keep investing
back or if you have bigger visions that
take on the world you might need
investment to happen or you might be
able to franchise your
if you have a proven system s working
probably not though if you're just
breaking even that's not you don't want
to buy a franchise from a company that's
just breaking even because if you are
just breaking even then the franchisee
coming into it they're not gonna be
breaking even because they're not going
to be as good as you typically and so I
would want to see that you are making
some good money so that if I can make
half of that I'm still really really
really happy as a franchisee so those
are my thoughts even yeah and I was an
investor - if you're not break even yeah
probably gonna get killed in the
valuation Joshua is talking about
storytelling what do you guys do with
storytelling in your marketing did I
lose John I see a frozen face on John
alright I'll continue on solo Joshua I
agreement storytelling super important
and being a face for the brand right
like I think every entrepreneur should
be on video even if it's not even if
you're not the most eloquent speaker
just do something that helps me see your
passion for what you're doing your
ability to tell a story is the
difference it's like why am I gonna buy
from you when I could buy from big safe
company that I I know is gonna deliver
results I'm gonna buy from you
small-time persons and entrepreneur just
getting started because I love your
story because I feel your connection
because I feel like you're gonna serve
me better and I think most entrepreneurs
do the opposite thing they do the wrong
thing they have a really corporate
professional-looking website that
doesn't tell their story and then if I
can't tell the difference between you
and everybody else I'm just gonna beat
you down on price like why am I gonna
buy from you you have to give me
something that's way better or I'm just
gonna compare on price what else we got
what else we got Vinny Evan how many
times were to tell you that you're
awesome how how I just kind of thinking
you Benny appreciate it man I do this
for all you guys maybe one question I'm
wanting to another hang on after this
you guys can check it out if you had a
website where you could livestream like
you're doing now but you could build a
community on this website make money on
views tips subscriptions would you do
live on it I'm not totally understand
the question I feel like a lot of the
platforms already exist and are really
exciting so we've got YouTube hangouts
we've got blab we've got periscope all
options where you can do live streaming
I would think
can you build the community that's the
hardest part that's the hardest part for
any of those new technologies that are
setting up the technology itself is not
that difficult to do live video is not
that difficult can you build a community
around it then you can monetize on top
of it John is back John and we got to
wrap up I know we're kind of crunched on
time for people who want to learn more
about tubs where can they find you guys
top smithing franchise that's like the
piece we're doing with you kind of
thinks in this and I speak people belief
in sin don't you ever just learn about
you want to share them with you guys
cool will do John thanks for making the
time thank you all for watching and
thank you thanks Evan